this week's guest video was pitched to
me as a puzzle and I couldn't solve it
so please welcome physicist TJ to town
homes who's going to show you the same
puzzle and then solve it with mats Jade
take it away here's a puzzle for you you
have a painting a piece of string and
two pins stuck in a wool can you hang
the painting in such a way so that if
you remove either one of the pins the
painting Falls the thing to focus on
here is how to tie the string around the
pins not any of the physics of the
objects so if you tie the string in the
normal way one would hang a painting
this obviously won't work it's pretty
easy to think of ways we can tie the
string so it falls when one of the pins
is removed but the challenge is to make
it fall if either one is removed pause
the video now if you'd like to try it
for yourself
so what we're working towards is a way
to tie the string around both pins as a
whole that neither one individually
so there are a few different ways to
solve this puzzle but we're going to do
the one which takes us through knot
theory knot theory is the mathematical
study of tangled systems as this is a
problem about tangling things together
chances are not theory will come in
handy with puzzles like these it's
sometimes hard to know where to even
begin a common technique mathematicians
use is to strip away everything but the
most important features so let's think
about what we can get rid of what parts
of the problem aren't providing us with
any useful information let's look at the
painting it's cool but isn't really
telling us anything
it's just joining the two ends of the
string if we get rid of it and tie the
string together we can reframe the
question as can we hang the string so
that if either one if the pins is
removed the string will fall it's just a
simpler version of the same question
sorry fashionable chicken what else is
unnecessary and
let's take a look at these pins
basically nothing matters about them
except how they interact with the string
and the fact that they don't interact
with each other we don't care about
their position size shape or color we
don't even care that their pins
mathematically it makes sense to want to
deal with just one type of object
instead of two imagine reading a story
that's written in both English and
Chinese sure both languages make up the
whole story but it would be much easier
to work with if it was all the same
language this is exactly what we're
going to do now translate our problem
all into the same language the language
of not Barry by converting our pins into
strings all the properties we care about
are still there if we tie them shut they
can't interact with each other and they
can't wrap our original string in knot
theory a closed string is called a knot
and a group of entangled knots is called
a link now we can reframe the question
again as can you tie the three knots so
that when together they're interlocked
but if you remove one the others fall
apart so far we've gotten rid of a bunch
of information but we haven't really
isolated what's important what should we
focus on if we want to solve the puzzle
well there's really only one way a
string can interact with another it can
cross over them or it can cross under
the crossings are the only things we
have control over and are the key to
unlocking the puzzle the crossings
basically determine one knot from
another but the thing is the same
crossing can look very different this
makes knots hard to reason about in an
organized way it's like if you had all
the components of a story but had no
idea what order they were meant to be in
but if we organized the crossings we can
reason much more clearly about the knot
let's take this random link of two knots
if I start on a random string at a
random point and start following this
string drawing on my paper as I go we
can keep track of all the crossings in
an organized way we keep going until we
come back to where we started we've just
created something called a braid diagram
knot theorists use these to model all
kinds of links the point of braid
diagrams is to keep track of the
crossings while getting rid of all the
unnecessary information distracting us
in a braid diagram the lines
representing our strings of
old strands if we label the strand
positions one two and three when the
strand and physician one crosses over
the Strand in position two we can label
this crossing X and when the Strand in
position one crosses under the Strand in
position two we'll call this inverse X
as it basically undoes what X just did
when the Strand in position two crosses
over the Strand in position three we'll
call this Y and when the stranded
position two crosses under the Strand in
position three we'll call this inverse Y
this notation is called a braid group
and actually everything we need to know
about our problem is encoded in these
letters the way these letters work is
that the X and inverse X cancel and the
Y and inverse Y cancel but they only
cancel out if they're next to each other
so coming back to our problem we want
the knots to be interlocked as a whole
but none of them looked individually to
another so if we think about this in
terms of our braid group removing a knot
is like removing all crossings involving
that knot if we remove the green string
all the x's will be removed and if we
remove the pink string all the Y's will
be removed what we want is a
configuration where as a whole nothing
cancels but if we remove either term
everything cancels let's see what we can
do we've got three strings our system is
symmetric so what we do first really
doesn't matter let's just start with an
X remember the pins can't interact with
each other so we have no choice but to
do another X or an inverse X we don't
want to have an X and an inverse X next
to each other because we don't want
anything to cancel yet so we'll do
another X crossing this is just like
wrapping one string around the other we
could keep going like this with the x's
but we need to include the other string
so let's do some Y's now because we want
our terms to cancel out in the end that
means every X needs an inverse X and
every Y needs an inverse Y if we do two
inverse Y crossings now they'll
immediately cancel out the Y's we just
did which isn't what we want so let's
try to invest X's now we can do to
invest Y's so let's take a look at where
we're at
if you remove all the Y terms the
remaining X terms cancel each other out
and if you remove all the X term
the remaining items cancel each other
out but when everything is together
nothing cancels that's exactly what we
want now let's work backwards to the
original puzzle chickened and all we can
use the braid diagram to model our link
let's see if it has the property we want
that when all three of them are together
they're locked but if you remove one the
others fall apart yep and now let's
bring back the chicken in the pins okay
guys this is it so now we're going to
map our braid group notation on to our
system of pins so remember from the
great group diagram that basically a
double X correspond to wrapping one
string around the other and a double
inverse X cursed Wonder to undoing that
move so here we're going to say that a
double X corresponds to wrapping around
a pin clockwise and a double inverse X
corresponds to undoing that move which
would just be wrapping around a pin
counterclockwise so double X double
inverse X double Y double in this way so
let's do it
double X double Y double inverse X
wrapping around counterclockwise double
inverse way so now the moment of truth
[Music]
that's not a tit so this definitely
wasn't the easiest on most
straightforward way to solve this puzzle
so why did we do it this way well now we
have this whole framework for solving
this problem for any number of pins
easily if we want to add another pin to
the puzzle this would be a nightmare to
brute-force but we can just work
backwards from our braid group and it's
simple today we use knot theory to solve
a fun puzzle but it actually leads to
some very fundamental mathematics we
were searching for a way to wrap the
string around both pins as a whole but
neither one individually but more
broadly we had to keep track of the
relationships between smaller parts of a
bigger system this kind of connection
has led to deep insights in many areas
of science just recently people have
been exploring the design of quantum
computers using particles that behave
just like the braids that we saw in this
video so if you want to win a Nobel
Prize someday better start saying some
nut Thank You Jade go subscribe to up an
atom I would recommend starting with her
video on quantum tunneling next week a
video that may leave you breathless
you